kyler murray and company going to santa
clara on a crazy day with air quality
index issues and the possibility the
game being relocated looming over
everything until the plane took off from
arizona on saturday and it looked like
everything was a go
the cardinals get it done and chris i
picked the right score
i just didn't go with the right winner
as much as i wanted to i talked myself
out of it and i wish i hadn't because i
had a feeling the cardinals were going
to do something they they competed well
last year with the 49ers and they had
something ready for week one and for the
defending division champions the
defending one seed to fall at home to go
to 0-1 to a division rival i know fans
not there makes it feel different but
that this this is huge for the cardinals
and it's huge in a bad way for the 49ers
it is i mean first off i got to just
talk about kyla murray for a second i
mean what what is it with these young
quarterbacks mahomes lamar deshawn
watson
i'm just amazed that they're maturity
they're just
never getting flustered
just nothing never bad an eye no matter
how big the moment who who they're
playing against i'm just amazed by it i
really am you know and san francisco
learned the lesson yesterday they had a
chance they really did
they had a chance early on to really
kind of grab the game by its you know
proverbial horns or whatever and control
it all right thank you yes thank you but
but they did you know when you really
look at it there's the the block punt
sets up the cardinals for the first
touchdown they have a fourth and one on
the one foot line they don't get a
touchdown there
cardinals ball points left on the board
as you know i mean just like any team
out there i don't care who you are when
you start to squander those type of
opportunities
it's this is the national football
league you opened the door for
a team that might have been trying to
find its way to finally get some
confidence to go okay hey yeah we belong
on this field and then the other thing
is with murray he's the equal he's the
great equalizer of that 49ers defense
he's really their kryptonite in a lot of
ways because of the way kingsbury
spreads the field a lot of quick and
short passes and then his ability to
scramble
it negates the 49ers great pass rush
they can't really pin their ears back
and just fly because they know if they
fly and miss them
you'll get zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom like
we saw already in one of those
touchdowns with kyla murray where he
scrambled for what was that mike a
22-yard run where it looked like a video
game so he is a tough matchup and the
cardinals the way they play are a tough
matchup for the san francisco 49ers and
that zone defense that's so reliant on
that front four getting home
26 for 40 for 230 yards one touchdown
one pick 13 rushes for 91 yards a
touchdown and two sacks she had 100
rushing yards until the last two plays
of the game when you when your victory
formation is shotgun formation you're
gonna lose rushing yards that's the big
dynamic for the cardinals nine yards
gone because he was in shotgun he lost
five yards then four yards on the last
two snaps of the game because they
didn't just line up and put him under
center like they usually do uh in a
situation like that but that's a good
problem for the cardinals to have that's
a new problem and they have a new weapon
in deandre hopkins
plenty of love already being shared
between hopkins and kyler murray for all
the times they connected yesterday but
you know chris what i was thinking
you don't want de'andre hopkins to
become a crutch for kyle murray the same
way he was a crutch for deshaun watson i
think the ball needs to be spread around
a little bit more than that well yes but
but we'll see what will they do off of
it you know a crutch player can be great
if your offensive coordinator knows how
to use that crutch player and go
okay i know he's a crutch player but i'm
going to use him as a pawn now and i'm
going to continue to try to teach my
quarterback hey we're using him as a
decoy here on this play because we throw
in the ball so much and you're going to
have to continue to infuse things like
that in the offense that's what the
great offenses do and i think yeah there
was moments you could say in deandre
hopkins in houston they didn't do enough
of that to find ways to use him as a
decoy
but we'll see i mean again cliff
kingsbury second year in the nfl
continues to impress kyla murray that
combination they put pressure on you on
the offensive side of the ball and then
you know one of the big questions we had
too was their defense
and
they they really played really good
football yesterday against the 49ers and
of course the 49ers weren't at full
strength either so when you got george
kittle who gets hurt because of a crappy
screen pass from your quarterback and he
exposes them there and then you have a
bunch of receivers that are already
banged up going to the football game you
saw a less than average passing attack
and really an average game by jimmy
garoppolo other than one play and i just
don't care who you are when you add up
all these things we've just said there
it's gonna be tough to win a football
game
before we break down what happened with
the 49ers consider this as it relates to
deandre hopkins he had 14 catches for
151 yards yesterday 16 targets the next
guy on the list for targets was larry
fitzgerald and chase edmunds and
christian kirk also five each christian
kirk a lot of hype and hope for him five
targets one catch zero yards but 16
targets for hopkins more than three
times
what the next guy's got and uh yeah that
won't yeah that won't fly you're right
it's not gonna fly consistently there's
no doubt about that that's why again
it's the perfect matchup what does san
francisco do mike they play that seattle
scheme they never man they never double
it's my problem with this scheme
sometimes it's things like this there's
going to be other defenses arizona's
going to play they're going to have
lockdown corners like a jalen ramsey
well they'll go hey we'll put jalen on
you sometimes we'll put jalen and
somebody else on you and we'll do all
these crazy type things that's not the
way this defensive system works and
that's why it's it's a tough matchup for
them and it's why arizona seems to hang
around and be a gnat
and bother the 49ers
throw that tweet back up there that was
deandre hopkins after the game making it
clear this is what you all wanted to see
now when he traded when he tweeted
grateful the other night it supposedly
was about him being on jimmy fallon not
about the texans getting their butts
kicked without him i have a feeling
that's not about jimmy fallon no that's
what you all wanted to see that's about
the cardinals and hopkins and 14 catches
for 151 yards you mentioned jimmy
garoppolo's performance of 49ers
performance chris i mean you know you
you know kyle shanahan as well as anyone
uh
wha what's what's his reaction gonna be
to this well i i mean i don't think he's
gonna be happy with his offensive
execution across the board they didn't
run the ball all that well that's
something they're used to doing as far
as dominating the line of scrimmage
there nothing really to speak of the
past game was really inconsistent too
other than that one big play to raheem
mostert they never really got anything
going and then especially when kittle
got hurt that was a big blow to the
football team because
i'm sure shanahan
had
more than
normal
like
uh plays than george kittle because of
the injuries they have at the wide
receiver position so then you cut him
out that's one less weapon and then you
know what we saw at the end of the game
you know
i i got to address that you know there
was just quite honestly throws that
should be hit for touchdowns that could
have won the game there was an out and
up to kendrick bourne and kendrick
bourne i know i saw on social media last
night he said it was his fault he's got
to come back i mean he's being a great
teammate that was a crap throw i don't
know what else to say and then on the
fourth down hey it said out route guy's
open he threw it late throw it behind
him threw it soft lets the guy break on
the ball knocks it away so they didn't
play good football they're gonna have to
go back to the drawing board and and get
used to being hunted like they are as
the uh super bowl you know attendee last
year
there was one throw near the end where
it was just like
jimmy garoppolo threw it up for grabs
and there was a cardinal and there was a
49er in the end zone and it wasn't like
a traditional 50 50 ball i mean it was a
little i think that's the one you're
talking about the one where it was put
his hands up and it hit his hand right
right yeah it was two kids
jostling for position his dad threw him
a candy bar that's what it looked like
yeah no there was uh i think a number of
underwhelming looking throws that came
out of the hand of jimmy garoppolo
yesterday and again this is what we
talked about a little on our podcast
when we did our picks and things like
that the question of the 49ers is still
going to be jimmy garoppolo until he
shuts everybody up because again what we
saw yesterday is when the shanahan run
scheme
can't dominate and things like that and
serve up plays on a silver platter can
jimmy garoppolo pick up the slack and go
hey guys i make 27.5 million jump on my
shoulders well i'll make some plays here
and that's been very spotty through his
career there in san francisco so far so
we'll see where it goes
well we have some kyle sound you know i
know i'll tell you after the sound the
specific reason why they lost the game
here's kyle after the game
we had a number of chances to win that
game you know i thought we started out
very well um
that we had a chance to run away with a
little bit in the first half anytime you
average eight yards of play and you're
holding them pretty good on the other
side of the ball i thought we'd have
more points to show for than what we did
um
it's i know why we didn't you know we
didn't convert one third down in the
first half we didn't convert one fourth
down and we didn't convert in the red
zone so no matter how well you do on
first and second down you're not going
to get any points
when you are offering all the other
situational areas
dominant teams overcome that though and
i really do think that the reason they
lost you saw that picture there what
happened to the to the skater hat you
can't change hats i thought his wife had
made it clear to him he's got to wear
the hat from last year that is not the
hat from last year you're right that's a
new hat that's why they lost period all
right analytics yep analytics you're
right that's next level analytics i'm
about to say i'm gonna have to send the
text message over to the shanahan family
and tell them to get their crap straight
what are they thinking there yeah but he
said it that was a great explanation
you know and again some of the things he
mentioned about
you know as far as red zone
third down those are quarterback areas
those are cool
the great quarterbacks yesterday didn't
have issues there you know again you got
to be able to make a play and i know
their offense is a little banged up
right now and not that way but again
this was the the arizona cardinals it's
not exactly the steel curtain either and
their pass rush wasn't that overwhelming
to where plays couldn't be made and
things like that so they got to go back
to the drawing board they got to get
healthy uh and hopefully george kittle
is healthy because that'll be a real big
blow to them too if if he can't play for
a few weeks
and that's where stats can be misleading
consider this jimmy garoppolo's numbers
were good and passer rating and i like
the passer rating stat because it stands
the test of time it's been around
forever it's apples to apples but jimmy
garoppolo had 103 passer rating
yesterday kyle murray had a 78
yeah exactly right
wrong exactly you know i mean yeah it's
too much put on completion percentage
and just touchdown passes you get too
much of credit for that at a time i mean
yeah it was a nice play to raheem moster
but you and me could have thrown that
come on you know so that's there is
context does matter and you certainly
knew who the better quarterback was on
the field in the game yesterday
they need receivers who are effective
they need debo samuel back he was placed
i think on injured reserve right before
the weekend so that means he's out for
three weeks and that's one of the things
we got to get used to this season the
roster flexibility rules allow a player
to be put on ir for just three weeks
usually you hear that and you think this
is bad this is serious and they have
stressed you can use it this year for
minor injuries because they want to have
maximum players available in the event
of a covet 19 outbreak and it's going to
create a situation where there will be
teams that stash players but that's fine
they're accepting that because that's
the balance they're striking to ensure
that maximum players are available hey
debo's not going to be available the
first few weeks get him off the roster
get someone else on so that's just one
more body that's here in the event that
we have an issue with covet 19. but you
know what
the best news is
even though it was weird yesterday to
see all those empty stadiums
not a not a hint not a whiff not an
issue with the pandemic hopefully that
will continue
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports